[Music]
our latest cbs news battleground tracker
poll finds president trump
behind in two states he is targeting for
victory
democratic nominee joe biden has a nine
point lead in minnesota
which the president came close to
winning in 2016
and biden is three points ahead in
arizona where the president campaigns
today
in our poll half of registered arizona
voters say
biden would do a better job handling the
corona virus
nancy cordes has been talking to voters
there all weekend and joins us from
tempe nancy what are voters telling you
well anthony they're telling us that
they are angry
and that while president trump won this
state
four years ago the pandemic is now
really shaping the race
in 2020 and in fact voters who say that
they've been
financially impacted by the virus were
far more likely to say
they're ready for a change
in phoenix from outdoor cafes
to hiking trails to the golf course
one issue kept coming up most biggest
concern to everybody certainly in my age
group
is health coronavirus
arizona is still recovering from a
massive summer spike
more than 2 000 deaths in july alone so
in our battleground tracker we asked
arizona voters
who would do a better job handling the
pandemic
they gave former vice president joe
biden a 13-point edge
i think anybody would do a better job
than donald trump to be honest with you
sherry tackett is a nurse practitioner i
felt like he was ignoring all the advice
and firing people that were giving him
good advice
82 percent of arizona republicans said
the trump administration is doing
all it can i don't know if anybody has
the real recipe to it
i think he could have done way better
federico lemon-meyer is a reluctant
trump supporter i think he's done many
wrong things but i think it's despite
the the
of that i think the country is going in
the right direction
oh yeah yes this is what campaigning
looks like in the covid era
we got some great conversations with the
people we caught up with one group that
only recently started canvassing again
with protective gear we knew that we had
we needed to turn out people and the
best way to do it is to have direct
conversations with them so
we decided we're going to get load up on
ppe face masks face shields and still go
out and talk to people
and what kind of reception do you get
are people afraid to open the door right
now
um actually they're more intrigued it
seems like with the protection that we
have on
there they want to know what we're doing
vice president biden
hasn't been to the state in person all
year
while republicans are taking a different
tack getting ready to welcome
mr trump to the state today for the
fifth time this year is it safe
for the president to travel here and
hold events it's very safe
the virus is just one reason this
reliably red
state is suddenly up for grabs i'm a
older white republican male who is
voting because of morality
not just policy and
i can't i can't vote for trump i just
think he's a crook
i think he is everything i don't want in
office tensions over the race
are riding high i've lost friends really
yes i've lost friends because of that we
met the murray skull family
after mass in downtown phoenix they made
up their minds
long ago trump yes why
because it's pro-life and i can argue
about racism but i can argue about life
that's a non-negotiable issue that's
negotiable for us and then there's
patricia matheus
a teacher i don't understand how latin
people can
like him now like 62 percent of the
latinos in our arizona poll
she plans to vote against mr trump i
think it's too much hate in that
latinos make up 30 percent of this
state's population and their numbers
have grown
since 2016. arizona has also seen
an influx of california residents
seeking jobs
and a lower cost of living all of that
and more has put the state's 11
electoral votes in play and there is a
real chance tony that this state
could go for the democrat for president
for the first time
since 1996. wow that's a great piece
nancy polls are one thing but i love
hearing from voters so we appreciate
that